im grunde haben wir thematisch schon
angerissen es ist ja putzig wir haben
jetzt seit knapp zwei jahren haben wir
diese corona pandemie wir haben zuerst
nicht so richtig gewusst was das virus
ist und inzwischen wissen wir eigentlich
auch nicht mehr was sie von uns selbst
entwickelten impfstoffe eigentlich
können und was sie nicht können wir
haben zuerst mit seltsamen erwähnten
operiert werden mit verdopplung zeit
operiert wir hatten oster ruhe versucht
wir hatten wellenbrechern lockdown und
ähnliche geschichten wir haben geschäfte
die ich gemacht alles hat irgendwie so
gewirkt es gab sogar
landesverfassungsgericht die gesagt
haben man könne keinen zusammenhang
erkennen zwischen den maßnahmen und dem
infektionsgeschehen dann gegen das im
sommer alles wieder ein bisschen zurück
jetzt kommt es wieder und wir stellen
fest auch die impfung haben wir nicht so
ganz verstanden offensichtlich sind sie
doch nicht der formel gemäss impfen
impfen das einzige allheilmittel
jetzt könnte man sich als politik
eingestehen wir wissen auch nicht alles
wir versuchen so ein bisschen was was
wir aber wissen ist dass der impfschutz
nachlässt also ganz logische folge
boostern musste ein booster das ist sehr
spät in angriff genommen worden und es
ist nach wie vor nicht so richtig
angelaufen dann gibt es beispielsweise
bayern und sachsen die immer darauf
verweisen dass in grenznähe die zahlen
so hoch sind also wenn da einen
zusammenhang konstruiert wird zwischen
dem grenzregime und dem
infektionsgeschehen dann muss man die
grenze zu machen heißt es wieder ja das
ist aber zu hart auch für die wirtschaft
die mittelständische gut also im
entweder reden wir hier über ein
aggressives virus oder geräten über
wirtschaftspolitik das kann es nicht
sein also entweder ist die bürger
erkennen einen kausalen zusammenhang
zwischen den handlungen der politik oder
sie erkennen nicht und ich habe den
verdacht dass ihnen oftmals eben nicht
erkennen und nur ein maßnahmenbündel
nach dem schneeballsystem darin sehen
[Musik]
man muss schauen wo wir herkommen also
du sprichst auch in österreich weil die
bayern sind an der grenze von österreich
und das warum sitzen
was immer denkt ist heute wurde ja in
österreich der komplette glaubt man
beschlossen ab montag und die besitzer
immer daran denken wir werden einfach
wahrscheinlich ganz genau so machen oder
sind zwei wochen glaube sind wir genau
damit ziehen jetzt wirklich alles
durchaus österreich gemacht hat nur
einen schritt später war der unterschied
zwischen deutscher und österreich ist
momentan dass österreich trotzdem viel
mehr angebote macht also alle jetzt was
booster info nun an geht das kann man
aber auch wirklich für die stadt
spazieren und sie an der theke oder im
stephansdom impfen lassen einfach so und
hier kriegt man sie eben durch das
system also österreich hat viele
angebote was alles an geht an impfungen
sondern auch nach wie vor gratis tests
die waren übrigens nie ausgesetzt und
hier hinkt man hinterher also eine rege
zahlen aber die maßnahmen werden im
selben also
kurz runter gebrochen ich auf österreich
die bieten zwar mehr an aber die zahlen
sind trotzdem horrend und sie müssen
locker machen deswegen glaube ich wird
uns nichts erspart bleiben hier bin der
absolut beide glaube auch wir werden
spätestens in vier wochen lang haben
hier können was ich dann eigentlich wenn
man wirklich wenn man wirklich glaubt
dass man es kriegen könnte keiner hat
den mut das jetzt zu machen aber da
müsste man doch eigentlich jetzt machen
damit man die weihnachts wären rein
schlittern weil wenn es in zwei wochen
passiert dann sind wir mittendrin wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatale ist
in der politik was sich ein bisschen
fortzusetzen scheint aus der ära angela
merkel ist muss erst die situation ganz
fatal sein bis man von hinten führen
dann entsprechend dann die situation
ändert das sehen wir bei der impfpflicht
auch die wird kommen weil die zahlen so
horrend sind weil die man früher nie
würde hätte durchsetzen können wurden
aber jetzt mit den zahlen kann man die
begründung dafür liefert der lok dann
kann auch es gemacht werden wenn die
zahlen so rennt sind dass man sagt es
gibt keine alternative und wir haben es
im letzten jahr erlebt der sollte der
lockout auch nur zwei wochen dauern er
wurde dann länger gemacht aber was mich
so ein bisschen skeptisch stimmt bei dem
beispiel österreich wir haben ja immer
hier auch hier an dieser stelle das
beispiel österreich hochleben lassen
österreich toll macht auf österreich
toll im grunde ist es ist auch in diesem
sommer als die eben sich geöffnet haben
und wir haben immer gesagt warum machen
wir das nicht jetzt sehen wir die
konsequenz
die konsequenz ist die konsequenz ist
der luft an der jetzt da ist und wir
aber wie gesagt die sartorius
sogar schon machen das heißt eigentlich
stehen wir genauso da wie österreich nur
die österreicher hatte und ich habe es
geliebt übrigens im sommer im kaufhaus
ohne maske tür rein und die konsequenz
ist der lockdown jetzt aber ich meine
angeblichen ländern das ist jetzt das
vorbild das ist das abschreckende
beispiel das denke ich dass wir alles so
wohl auch viele jetzt steht gegen die
schweden gut da das war wirklich so das
reich des bösen noch vor wenigen monaten
also irgendwie und das kann sich das
kann ich mir gut vorstellen dass sich
das auch noch mal ändern habe auch ein
objektives skepsis ob diese maßnahme
überhaupt funktionieren inklusive
lockdown wenn wir heute einen lock down
beschlossen ich wollte diesen konjunktiv
immer schon mal unterbringen wollte
einen unlock dann beschlossen dann
würden bis anfang nächster woche die
länder in deutschland ich glaube in
österreich ist ähnlich die verordnung
machen müssen um das ganze umzusetzen
das heißt wir reagieren jetzt auf einen
peak in den infektionszahlen der dann
nächste woche schon ganz anders aussieht
dann wären die verordnung umgesetzt und
wirken dann rein in einem sich
abschwächenden berg von infektionen bei
in der regel nach so einem höhepunkt
sehr viele genesenen da sind und die
kurven wieder runter gehen ich bin nicht
sicher ob es wirklich effektiv ist was
wir da machen ich bin anders rum
skeptisch als österreichische kanzler
scheinberg angekündigt dass da lockt und
jetzt bis 13 12 bleiben soll so und er
verspricht dass die maßen und dann enden
und dann geht's halt wieder weiter mit
dem lock on für ungeimpfte jetzt schon
wieder ein versprechen abzugeben dass er
vielleicht nicht halten können wird halt
die für dermaßen schwierig da wär's mir
schon lieber und ehrlicher zu sagen
zumal wir wissen es nicht also im ernst
und was man treibt drei zauberhaften das
wieder ändert nur damit die weihnachts
ruhige watt ist halt genau und da geht
ja auch um diese wirklich so völlig
prekäre kommunikation der regierung dass
man einfach immer wieder sozusagen auch
wissenschaftliche neue ergeben ist sie
sozusagen auf neue wahrheiten
präsentiert anstatt der bevölkerung
einfach mal auf zusammen wir haben uns
schon extrem viel geehrt wir haben uns
bei der maske geht wir haben uns beim
boosten wird möglicherweise irgendwie
uns auch jetzt wieder wir versuchen
irgendwie das beste für für die
bevölkerung zu machen und hoffen ihr
macht mit aber wir können es
letztendlich nicht sagen das wäre doch
viel glaubwürdiger aber von dem hört man
überhaupt nichts und darüber habe ich
auch mit dieser kommunikation hat man so
viele leute verschreckt dass man eben
sie dann am schluss nur noch zur impfung
zwingen kann aber da glaube ich dass das
hinterlässt dann echte auch politische
schäden weil wenn du keinen zu machen
willst und wird dann aber ich eigentlich
dazu genötigt dass das ist nicht einfach
vergessen in einem traum monaten das ist
ein politischer schaden der uns dann
noch länger beschäftigen wird